the prison trucks pull in just before
8:00 and unload their youthful looking
cargo they are shackled and
disorientated they look out of place but
the government says they're enemies of
the state they stand accused of
protesting or looting or disturbing the
peace and the authorities have rounded
up hundreds of people this week their
relatives queue up just around the
corner at Harare central magistrate's
court but they are unlikely to get a
seat
this aging structure wasn't designed for
mass trials why are you here today
Anastacia yeah my husband did me son
I've been taking they have been taken by
those they arrived at police mass plant
was in the field and my son was fetching
water so they just came and they have
scraped them start read them and they
put them in the truck they never said
anything
Joyce Abunda is here to see her
granddaughter
Cynthia one of dozens of juveniles
children who've been arrested and
detained
these allegations are not uncommon and
Zimbabwe scores are now trying these
children as adults lawyer job cicala is
representing 18 minors in court but he
says there isn't much he can do for them
are you surprised that you are in a
position where you are defending
juveniles absolutely the the rule of law
has been thrown through the window
even the the way how their proceedings
are taking place in our courts are
clearly demonstrating that the rule of
law has not been overthrown some of the
evidence that have been brought to this
court s exhibits I'm not only laughable
but is absolutely shocking
they will default that to me was a
dictator but the current dictator is
west of Don Roberto Gaby we went to
visit mrs. sue bunda in one of her Ari's
outer suburbs and she showed us what the
military did to her house last week we
also met her 16 year old granddaughter
Cynthia she's been released on bail
after collapsing three times in prison
how do you feel about this Wayne and I
know what she can see that I do for y z1
devadasi TD Cynthia who asked not to be
identified says the entire experience
has been terrifying
I was scared in the present cause from
Monday to anything I didn't eat anything
they didn't give us good day do you
think things will go back to normal
sometimes cause each and every day
they say the course should go further
feather feather feather and
this is a bomb in terrible people here
are afraid of the authorities and they
aren't far away the community police
station now resembles a military base
and the rules don't seem to apply to
them John sparks Sky News in Harare